hi everyone um good afternoon
um i'm priya natarajan i'm the current
director of the frankie program in
science and humanities
and i'm an astrophysicist i am just
really delighted you're here
uh this is to really give you a warm
welcome to our first convening
this fall as we open up our programming
for this academic year in person
and i'm really grateful that you all
are here we have a very exciting event
for this evening a wonderful
thought-provoking film by a very young
talented filmmaker and a year happens to
be a yale alum as well
more about that in just a minute
first i would like to start
with thanking our benefactors mr and mrs
richard and barbara frankie for their
generosity in supporting us and multiple
other activities at yale
as you all know um we lost mr frankie
this summer
and uh so there will be a memorial
service to honor his legacy
contributions and his unplugging support
for many cross-disciplinary activities i
think
as a flagship interdisciplinary program
that in um at yale that bridges the
so-called sort of you know two cultures
that cp snow came up with in the 1950s
the sciences and the humanities
here we have been catalyzing
intellectual collaborations across
disciplinary boundaries and silos
and as every year we are now delighted
to welcome many of our young
undergraduate graduate and post-doctoral
frankie fellows whose work actually
crosses many
disciplines
and before we move on to the event i'm
required to give you this notice
this event is being recorded and
photographed for educational archival
and promotional purposes including news
in print and on the internet and other
forms of media by attending this event
today you agree to the possibility of
your voice or likeness captured by these
means and used for such purposes without
compensation to you and hereby waive any
related right of privacy or publicity
so moving on to today's program we are
screening the film unconformity by the
filmmaker jonathan demaio after which we
will open up the floor to a q a
and we're really fortunate to have him
here this evening jonathan welcome back
to yale back home
after graduating in 2009 john received
yale's parker huang fellowship which he
used to help found espanola
a non-profit that began as a yale
undergraduate group
hispaniola is an education organization
that works with dominicans of haitian
descent who are at risk of statelessness
and the organization still runs a
university scholarship program which
john started in 2010 and he spent the
early 20 2010s between boston new york
and the dominican republic
working on film sets making his own
short films
and setting up programs and seeking
funding for his non-profit his 2014
short film without the ancestors played
at numerous festivals in the united
states and europe including the
pan-african film festival and the zenith
wow and his music videos with dominican
rappers chocola gimbi helped launch the
duo to national prominence in dr
at the beginning of 2014 john traveled
to the mojave desert to be in a field
camp manager
talk about the versatility and the
talented
you know yale undergraduates just a
range of i mean i've been here for 20
years and i'm still uh completely
astounded at the
multi-faceted talents these uh young
people have so he became a camp manager
field camp manager for a geology class
run by a yale college classmate this
trip sparked an interest in land rights
and geology in the west john started
traveling west to meet with geologists
ranchers native american tribes and
archivists and after years of research
writing and outreach uh his work has led
to this remarkable feature form on core
formulae along with unconformity john is
currently in post-production on two
short films hopefully jonathan you will
tell us a little bit more about it
before the q a dying to hear more and
developing many other movies
um and i think you know the testimony to
his talent is that not only was he just
the field camp manager but he used that
experience to learn and teach us all
something about the complexities of what
is going on
in
in the west so before starting today's
event um and we start with the screening
of the film
uh i would like to mention a couple of
upcoming events so we have an ongoing
learning by doing project for which we
are soliciting videos these are small
science do it at home experimental
videos that you can send us that we
share with kids around the world
and as part of our understanding the
nature of inference colloquium series uh
it's a virtual talk series uh professor
alexander pisso a distinguished
professor of philosophy at oxford will
be giving the talk on september 28th at
3pm
and then we have lined up for you a
virtual talk by journalist esther honing
on the sad state of agricultural
degradation in a small mexican fishing
village in early november and later on
in november we have a very exciting talk
by another of our illustrious young yale
alums um the star architect james ramsey
who is a former nasa engineer as well
and he'll be talking to us on november
10th so many treats to come
and
without further ado let me just turn
over uh to jonathan's film unconformity
and thank you jonathan for being here
and we're really looking forward to
talking to you after the screening and
thanks everyone once again let's enjoy
this film
[Applause]
very very moving
i sort of feel very emotional there are
many aspects about um
you know
academic life competitiveness
and our sort of obsession with the
materialist consumers catalyst culture
there's just so many things that we
could talk about
i just want to jump start the
conversation and then open it up
uh to everyone else um
so what about your field trip camp what
really got you started on sort of
looking at this sort of intersection
of really complex but
really moving
upsetting issues
um so i was
i was in the desert for a month mostly
during the day i was by myself because
the geologists would go out to the field
and i was actually editing the film at
the time so i would edit the film and
hang out with
everything else in the desert and there
were lots of strange things happening
because we were near 29 palms you would
run across
people ranchers other people out in the
desert
and it was right around the time that
clyde and bundy
and his
family uh violently
overtook some federal property or they
weren't paying their their ranching fees
so i became interested in
that and about wanted to learn about
ranching and i went out and met with
ranchers and started hearing their
stories um and the bundys are obviously
extremists
and
the initial drafts of the film were more
about bundy style um people with those
types of views but it wasn't ended up
where i wanted to go with the film
because
most rangers aren't the bunnies right
and um and i guess
somewhere in there obviously academic
culture fascinates you
and um
so i was curious um
about that character of alex
and so what sort of was there a
particular person that inspired you
there or is this this is like an
archetype that you kind of pulled out of
yeah more of an archetype more of an
archetype not one particular person
um
and i just you know she
she's very driven and she's very focused
and she's very selfish in a lot of ways
throughout the film and it's about her
journey of learning
not to be
but there wasn't a particular person
that inspired it but a lot of the
academic culture was
um and that sort of competitive nature i
had a lot of friends who were in
academia after
um we all graduated and hearing their
stories and then honestly my experiences
in the film world and seeing how people
behaved
climb in trying to get credit and so it
was a combination of those things
so i thought it was just beautifully
done and um
anyway i would like to open up to um
others and not follow jonathan
completely so if anyone else has
questions i think there is a roving
microphone or did you want to take this
one
how do we want to do this
can you hear me okay if i speak
in the back
yeah we can lend our microphones i think
we're both
thank you
i think just have people
stand up and speak okay because um we
may not be able to record this right or
are you
recording let me just spin this around
oh if you want to just have people uh
ask the questions i'll pick it up
okay okay
and we can hear them in the room anyway
anyone has a burning question
uh
i'm interested in the composition of it
um
and i
i guess it would be useful to hear you
say
more about the process
um
because it's a very
very visual film
uh
you know like the shots are very
[Laughter]
and i'm glad it's being recorded uh the
so i'm thinking about the i guess the
the um your own interest in
narrative and then also
uh image because it's you know it's very
like i said it's a very visual film
especially in the beginning
stages when she's alone the solitude
there's kind of
uh
transcendental
um insistence
kind of edward
abby kind of feel to it so i'm
interested in hearing you
talk about where in your composing
uh
the
the images and your construction of
images comes in
um is it
does that
come before parts of the narrative does
it arise out of the narrative do you
think okay i've worked through the
narrative and then when we've settled on
a location all that then i'll kind of
figure out the images
i mean it doesn't have to be either or
but it would be interesting to hear like
the the sort of
um procedural rhythm
composition does that make sense yeah um
so
a lot of it is you find the location and
then you
pick the best shot a fair amount of it
comes from that i knew that i wanted a
lot of
wides medium mods um
because i wanted to show the characters
in the space and i wanted people to feel
that
um so
um oh you know
as a when i met up with with hana our
director of photography we we basically
sat down and planned every single shot
in the film and what happens often is
you have to cut on the day you have to
cut a third of them because you don't
have time but a lot of you plan out
where you want to where where the camera
goes and you
you develop a style
you look at reference shots i was
looking at a lot of photography um i was
looking at a lot of robert adams
photography
when we were in pre-production and
showing those images to her
um and talking about them
and then also you know
some of the footage that we got i wasn't
even there for because we had b-roll we
had a friend friend come out and we
basically talked about the aesthetic
style and he came out with his drone and
his and his camera and he went out and
spent a couple days just finding finding
footage um
so it's sort of a combination of
of those things
yeah so actually i did want to follow up
and ask so was there a lot of
drone use for this or um yeah and some
of them are pretty obvious where you see
the camera following or flying or very
high in the sky but some of it is um
you know
when you have a camera on the ground in
the desert you don't really get that
perspective in that deep view and so
there are a bunch of still shots where
we just had the camera go up and look
straight out because it gives you
it just allows you to see the contours
of the desert better and you wouldn't
know that it's a drone shot because
usually you think drone you think fancy
helicopter style shots and my my
favorite drone shot is the one when
they're on the atv
and the camera just uh it jibs down to
the fence
um because
in traditional hollywood that shot would
have cost
by itself the level of the entire
production budget but with a drone you
just have a guy who's talented and he
does the shot and it just opens up what
you're able to do it's really and it
reads as a as a jib shot which is a
technical fun shot but i mean you know
as an astronomer i can't resist asking
right how come you didn't show the night
sky
uh
you're so beautiful
so
i just read an article about this new
film by jordan peele nope and he's he
used a new photography method to shoot
the sky that involves infrared cameras
and film cameras and then superimposing
them so if we had known about that four
years ago we would have done it but it
wasn't in the cards
well i mean i realized it's about rocks
i mean it's not about star space yeah
fake by the way that's what the web
telescope does now combines infrared and
regular photography
i
just wanted to say i'm not a film expert
i've known john for a long time and
in my freshman year in 1970 at the law
school auditorium
i went to see all about eve and joseph
mankowitz himself was there to answer
questions and i feel like in the
continuum for the same thing
congratulations
thank you
who wants to catch both mixed
jonathan it was wonderful to see it on
the big screen after having seen it
on the computer and i realized that
there was a lot that i missed the first
time and a lot that uh
that became clearer
the
the um
i was interested in how you combined
the story the personality of the young
woman the main character and uh
and the landscape
what what came first to you was it the
desolateness of the desert or what was
it that
because they all they all complement
each other obviously but what came first
when you were thinking about it or how
did you get to that creative process
um
it's hard to say
um i think
part of it was
you know i went out to the desert with a
friend who i met first week at yale and
seeing her go out into the desert and
then meeting more geologists who
they just go out sometimes for a year by
themselves and live in death valley just
doing research
and
of course my experience out there was
formative being
in that space
um and i was became interested in
who
who does that who goes out there and
spends time alone like that
um
because it's not what most people do
so um i'm just curious from your point
of view
what do you what do you expect the
viewer to take away
do you i mean do you have an expectation
you must right
um
i i don't know i try to i don't want
people to have a specific reaction to
the film i want them to enjoy it for the
reasons they enjoy it um
it's a hard question to ask a filmmaker
sorry i don't yeah
but um
now that you've seen it all come
together
i mean was there a portion of the film
the shooting the actual writing as well
as the filming that was particularly
challenging for you
um
i mean film filming in the desert on a
low budget uh is very hard um
the biggest logistical challenge really
was um just the distances that you know
we were near a small town but we were 20
minutes away and we were on two
different ranches we had you know we
were moving around the ranches with a
crew and location and and just making
sure everything is in the right place at
the right time is hard when you're when
sometimes you don't have phone service
or you don't have walkie-talkies um so
that's a big challenge um
and
um and and post-production
uh at fir you know at first i hated it
um because it's really painful to sit
with your footage and try to figure out
how to make a movie out of it but then
it becomes this really kind of amazing
process where you just sort of layer in
these elements and you get to see the
film become what it is going to become
and it's really exciting uh so
that is challenging because it takes so
much time we spent 18 days in principal
photography a couple days of reshoots i
had to go back to vegas to get some
b-roll during the pandemic
but really you're only filming for
25 days and then you spend two years in
an editing room getting feedback doing
test screenings going to festivals and
and doing the new music itself took over
a year um yeah it's really really
beautiful yeah connor
he's an amazing composer um yeah it was
a super that was an incredible process
too because he was we would get on a you
know
we would get on a call and just talk
about what instrumentation to use what
what to do and we were on a call
together when the capital was stormed so
every january 6 now connor and i have a
reunion call to to commemorate that
because we just stopped working and
watched the news together so
any other questions it's a question in
the back
how did you find the actors
um we worked with the casting director
so
um through one of our producers put us
in touch with the casting director who
was quite good um and through sort of a
series of events we weren't going to
work with her but then
she ended up being on the project and it
just opened doors for us in terms of
getting people that were good because
she
was very well respected and so
um
you know it's a very low budget film and
so agents obviously are asking for more
and more money but she was basically
able to say look this is the project
this is how much money they have do you
want to be in it and
really helped that process
i was very taken by the father yeah he
could have been a one-dimensional kind
of rancher type
but uh
he brought out many different parts of
him and he had a very expressive face
yeah he's wonderful yeah yeah he was
jeremy is a fantastic actor he he's
often
plays security guard types on on tv
shows people recognize him but he's got
an incredible range and he's also very
fun to have on set um the first week we
were only working with jack and alex the
two young actors and you know that were
earlier movies for them they haven't
done very much and everyone was kind of
nervous and
and jeremy came the second week and was
just like rolling around in the dirt and
making dad jokes and everyone kind of
loosened up and so it's really he was a
lot of fun to have around and he's it
was great
uh jonathan it's also my second time
watching this and i've noticed a lot of
things this time
um
i i want to really congratulate you on
all the breathing space you gave this
movie
visually
and in the dialogue and in the music
there's just a lot of
not silence but
slow down or spaces it just
and they spoke a lot uh
to the plot and
that was my second
actually more my question was how you
came up with such a great plot was this
something that um
kind of came to you at once or
did it develop
after you started a little bit it's a
fairly intricate plot but it's very
very clear and very interesting and
it's like you have a literary flair but
totally in film
so there were lots of iterations there
were lots of drafts different story
lines that were completely different
than this and i even ended up doing a
pretty large rewrite
four months before we filmed
you just have to sort of test it out and
a lot of the you look at you know you
study other movies you study other
scripts you see what works
um in similar genres or styles
um
so a lot of it is
sort of copying the masters to a certain
extent and this putting it into new
places and testing things out
and having good readers people that are
screenwriters and filmmakers and and
honestly often the best notes come from
actors because they're so attuned to
character
so you just want to be open to feedback
and and be ready to
to kill your darlings
because you just have to to to make a
script work
just a brief question i was very
impressed by the accuracy and the detail
of the geology facts
any response from the geology community
about these
discoveries and things the geologists
are mostly very enjoying it very much
which is exciting um
recently on twitter i saw someone post a
checklist of all the geology activities
that they got to see in the film um
so they're they're enjoying it they
approve they prove for the most part um
and uh
um
and they're also they're really they're
interested in the story about sort of
plagiarism and bullying and academia
they're they people are
it's not that's not a reaction i was
expecting but people are really
interested in that and want to talk
about that because it's things that
people have experienced so there's a lot
of interest in that
i think we have time for one more
question because they expect us to
get out of the room by six
hi so uh first thank you for the film um
i have zero academic cinema training
but i'm a big western fan
and i guess the analogy here is not lost
it's the setting it's the saving the
family ranch uh
plot line i guess alex is trying to save
her academic
uh range
i was wondering
how you sort of tie
i feel like this together where
usually one expecting conflict between
uh you know protagonist and the villain
and here the conflict
at least to me and
especially for it and i'm trying to do
science the conflict is not really
against anybody um except
minor plagiarism at the beginning there
isn't really any
bad
person
to contrast against with
um so sort of interested in how that's
sort of weaved together to generate
conflict against
mother nature or
yeah i think that's part of it and and
you know it's a movie
in part about the climate crisis and
about extinction events both big and
small
very old and somewhat new so
i think that sort of provides um
some of the context there for the for
the conflict and for
for eddie's character jason lowry to
also
uh
provide that sort of push to the
ranchers which is a very difficult to do
because
a lot you know a lot of the dialogue i
didn't you know you hear you talk to
blm bureau of land management range cons
or you talked to ranchers and they were
often
talking past each other but
trying to help each other in certain
ways as well and so there was a natural
conflict there but i really didn't want
to make anyone out it's more complex
than
good and bad and i wanted to try to
share that complexity um with some of
that complex yeah i mean i think
actually i thought you succeeded
beautifully because
there was this uh tension without an
allusion to black and white and i think
i caught the backdrop i mean i like the
extinction the ancient extinction event
and the contrast with the current
struggle
and the way that you showed um you know
the blm character at the end of the day
we are all in this potential
extinction event together
and sort of a certain kind of truth i
actually like that tension i like the
fact that you started off with that
plagiarism thing and then that you were
done with it you know that sort of went
away but it that whiff was through there
throughout the film right i mean that
sort of
uh carried on so i actually liked the
fact and i sensed
sort of tension and conflict
not so much between good and bad but
between uh almost like
thriving and survival thriving and
surviving you know academic thriving
what it takes and then it's like down to
survival and you know i thought that
those tensions were really really well
done so
i was it was um
i mean i i mean i'm stunned that you
know i i was going to ask you you've not
been in a phd program right and
yes i was pretty stunned at the sort of
the layers
that you manage to get at
so um if there are no further questions
let's all thank jonathan again for
fantastic
many
and thank you so much for coming today
of course